[Music]
there are several ways to create copy or
migrate virtual machines to your new
google cloud vmware engine private cloud
i'm eric gray from vmware and in this
video i'll show you how to deploy vms
from template and iso image via content
library
[Music]
log on to the google cloud vmware engine
portal and launch the vsphere client
navigate to content libraries and click
on the default content library that's
present in your new private cloud
deployment
the content library supports several
types of templates that you can use as
the basis for vm deployment
let's look at a couple of different ways
to get items into the library
vmware offers a container optimized
linux distribution called photon os and
you can import an ova directly into the
library by using the download url from
the photon website
you can also upload iso images from your
local machine
be sure to use descriptive names so
different versions can be introduced
over time
once the content is ready click over to
the vms and templates view and select
the workload vms folder
select new virtual machine from the
actions menu to open the deployment
wizard
to create a vm that's based on the
uploaded ova select deploy from template
and choose the item
next give the new vm a name and select
the workload resource pool as the
destination
[Music]
complete the remaining steps of the
deployment wizard and be sure to choose
the workload network segment that you
created previously
you cannot use the default networks for
workloads they are for private cloud
management functionality only
to learn how to create a new vmware nsx
network for workloads see the previous
video in this series
power on the new vm and log in through
either the vmware remote console or the
built-in web console
[Music]
from there you can verify that your vm
has network connectivity and you can
start setting up applications and
services on your private cloud
to create a new vm and install an
operating system from an iso image use
the new virtual machine menu item to
launch the deployment wizard
use the default selection and proceed
through the wizard give the vm a name
and choose the workloads resource pool
as the destination
you can leave the default vm
compatibility setting or change it to
meet your business requirements
choose the guest os type and tune
virtual resources as needed
be sure to select a vmware nsx network
segment that you created previously
not one of the default infrastructure
networks
configure the dvd drive to use a content
library iso file and check the box to
connect during boot
finish the wizard and select the new vm
power it on and open a remote console
perform the os installation and finish
by rebooting
verify that vmware tools are properly
running inside the guest for best
performance and manageability of your
workloads
now you know how to deploy your first
workloads into google cloud vmware
engine
for more guidance on configuration and
workload management check out the other
videos in this series
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]